LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
Today, I'm going to be chatting
with Fred Chung, whose job here
at Google is really
making your life easier.
He's one that helps strategize
how we speak with developers,
so that we can build
better products
and you can build better apps.
I've been looking forward to
this day for quite awhile,
actually.
FRED CHUNG: Likewise.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Because it's always
good to speak with good
developer advocates.
FRED CHUNG: And
thanks for the coffee.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh,
you're very welcome.
It's good coffee, too.
And it's real.
[LAUGHTER]
So tell us about yourself, and
what brought you to Google,
and what you've been doing.
And how'd you get to
what you do today?
FRED CHUNG: Yeah, absolutely.
A bit of background
information about myself.
Before Google, I
used to be a software
engineer in the enterprise
integration space.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
you really wrote code.
That's not marketing.
FRED CHUNG: I wrote code.
[INAUDIBLE] works.
And when I joined Google,
I was a sales engineer
working with
AdWords API clients,
helping them integrate
with AdWords,
using the AdWords API, which
is a SOAP-based technology.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we
all remember SOAP, right?
FRED CHUNG: Yeah,
we had a lot of fun.
And then I moved to Android
as a developer advocate,
back in the Android 2.0 days.
LAURENCE MORONEY: 2.0.
Wow.
Way back.
FRED CHUNG: Do you
remember the code name?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Eclair.
I never forget a dessert.
FRED CHUNG: Absolutely.
We've made a lot of progress
both on the platform
and the app ecosystem front.
I remember one of the first
presentation assignments
was to go to Barcelona, a
conference in Barcelona,
and talk to the audience
about what is Android.
Back then, it was a relatively
new mobile operating system.
We had to tell them that,
OK, it's got a camera.
It's got a few sensors.
We have a lot of fun back then.
And since then, things
have evolved dramatically.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Have come a long way.
FRED CHUNG: Based
on what we've seen
developers have done
in the past few years,
it's been amazing to see
the sophisticated apps that
are coming out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And also, with
the more sophisticated devices
and the things that
they can do, consumers
are a lot more demanding
for new types of apps
and new, sophisticated
requirements
that developers have to meet.
It's quite a challenge, right?
FRED CHUNG: Yeah.
On Android, as you know, we
have not only film and tablets,
we also have Android Wear
on your wrist, Android TV,
and Android Auto
in your vehicles.
So these things represent
a lot of new opportunities
for developers.
And we're in an exciting time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Developers being able to
meet these new sophisticated
requirements need
a lot of support.
And I think that's where your
role comes in as a developer
platform manager.
So as people are going on
to the Android platform
and going on to the
Google platform,
they need to learn how to
do all these new things.
And that's where
you fit in, right?
So tell us a little bit about
what a DPM actually does.
FRED CHUNG: Yeah, DPM stands
for Developer Platform Manager.
Let's talk a little bit
about developer platform,
what does it mean.
If you look at Google, we offer
quite a few developer products
that allow third-party
developers to build
innovative solutions-- for
example, Google Maps API, which
allows mobile application
developers, Android, iOS,
and web-based developers
to easily integrate maps
into their solutions.
Or Google Play
Game Services that
allow game developers to
build more engaging games,
to give you-- spend
time with them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
that common functionality,
like high-score tables and
that kind of stuff, too.
FRED CHUNG: Yeah, leader
boards, and quests,
and stuff like that.
But the point is, we look at
the collection of API products
and platform and tools
as a developer platform.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
FRED CHUNG: And as a
developer platform manager,
I work very closely with the
Android product and engineering
teams to help them figure out
the developer outreach strategy
for their products.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK,
so it's like you're
advocating on behalf of the
developer with our engineering
team, as well as vice versa.
FRED CHUNG: Yes.
We actually see developer
advocacy as a two-way street.
Not only do we want to
use relevant opportunities
to educate and
inspire developers
on certain new features,
best practices,
and third-party
integrations, we also
want to use the opportunity
to listen to developers.
In fact, we have multiple
channels available
both online and offline.
So if we're online, in
the case of Android,
we have +androiddevelopers
on Google+.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And that's
a really big community.
FRED CHUNG: Yes,
with a lot of traffic
and activities on a daily basis.
And that's very exciting.
And in the offline
world, we also
work with Google
Developer groups.
We partner with them from
time to time to run events.
And that's a great avenue
for us to get feedback
from developers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So if developers out
there are watching this,
really want to give us feedback,
they can go to those ways.
They can go to
the Android+ site.
They can go to a Google
Developers group.
We've got newsgroups,
that kind of thing.
FRED CHUNG: That's right.
And if you've built
interesting solutions,
let us know through one
of these channels, too.
We would love to learn
about the innovations.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We always
hear about this thing
called developer experience.
And a good developer
experience is very important.
What is that to you?
What is developer
experience, and what do we
do at Google to provide a
great developer experience?
FRED CHUNG: Developer
experience is a very broad area.
And in particular, we care
about things such as API design.
We want to make sure the
design that goes into the API
makes sense to developers.
They have to conform
to certain semantics
that developers
are accustomed to.
For example, we recently
extended the notification APIs
in the support library,
to support not only phones
and tablets, but also Android
Auto and Android Wear,
these new form factors.
We want to make sure the design
conforms to certain standards.
So that's why we have things
like car extender and wearable
extenders in the
support library.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
we build a core API
but then are able to
extend that consistently,
as new devices come on board.
FRED CHUNG: Exactly.
And when it comes to
educating developers,
we want to make sure that
we have adequate content,
both on
developer.android.com, which
is our official documentation
site that educates developers
the best practices and APIs
associated with features.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And there
are some great samples on there
as well that folks can
download and dissect and learn
from that.
FRED CHUNG: Yeah.
We want to build educational
samples that help developers
appreciate certain features.
And also, we want to
highlight best practices.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We spoke
a little bit earlier about
how new sophisticated
requirements are coming online.
What is it that makes
development difficult nowadays?
What are the challenges
that developers may face?
FRED CHUNG: Getting the
user experience right
is an important thing that
developers need to be aware of.
And I think that's
one of the challenges
that developers these
days have to face.
So for example, these
different screen sizes--
you don't necessarily want to
say you have an existing phone
app.
You don't want to
shrink it to your watch.
And likewise, you don't
want to just stretch it
on your big-screen TV.
You really want to rethink
the user experience that go
on to these new form factors.
If you have access to a
designer, work with them.
And if you don't have
access to a designer,
on our documentation
site, we have
some design-focused content.
And we have also engineers and
design content on our YouTube
channels as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And isn't it also within Android
Studio as you're building,
there are templates for the
different design form factors?
FRED CHUNG: Yes.
Let's talk about Android Studio.
Android Studio is the de facto
IDE for Android developers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we
all love Android Studio.
FRED CHUNG: Yes, we do.
So in Android
Studio, we have added
templates for new projects.
So if you're in a process
of creating a new project,
you can selectively add
additional capabilities.
For example, you can add watch
support for Android Wear,
Google Glass support
to your application.
So the idea of this
is that developers
get to focus on
their core expertise
and let us work
on the boilerplate
by automating the
generation process.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
And if the developer
experience is good,
the consumer's experience
is going to be good, right?
FRED CHUNG: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So you've been
working as a developer platform
manager with Google for a while.
And you've worked
with developers,
and you see all these
great opportunities that
are out there for developers,
be it web, and cloud,
and wearables, and mobile.
And I'm sure it can be quite
confusing for developers
to be focused onto
where to get started
on the next great opportunity.
What would your advice be?
FRED CHUNG: I think mobile
platforms is definitely
one important area
that developers
should think really hard about.
And when you look at mobile
applications, a lot of them
are actually powered by
some sort of cloud back end.
So it would be good to look at
these two areas simultaneously.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
then also forgetting,
while all this is going on,
there's also emerging markets.
And cloud and mobile is
huge in emerging markets.
So do you have advice
for developers thinking
about getting into
these emerging markets,
looking for the next user base?
FRED CHUNG: So I
think emerging market
is in particular a
very interesting area,
because consider how
users in emerging markets
are accessing the internet.
They're using their phones and
tablets instead of desktops.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well, there's
also-- in emerging markets,
they may be
accessing via phones.
But there's potentially
disconnected scenarios.
A lot of these
emerging companies,
they don't have the same level
of network infrastructure
as maybe eastern Asia, or
western Europe, or United
States and Canada have.
So there's unique challenges
for a developer building
for that kind of thing.
FRED CHUNG: The
implication for developers
is that when you architect
your applications,
you need to think
about these scenarios.
You want to make sure that
your application maybe
support offline capabilities,
or make sure your applications
to perform efficiently
on a network,
on the memory, and the CPU.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
And there's-- I understand
you've put together a lot
of material to help
developers with that,
some DevBytes around that.
So what were they called again?
I can't remember the--
FRED CHUNG: Yeah,
so the team has
put out a series of DevBytes
called Android Performance
Patterns.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Performance
patterns, of course.
Performance matters.
FRED CHUNG: Performance
matters, right?
So always keep
performance in mind
when it comes to creating
your applications.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool, cool.
So anything else that you'd like
to talk to developers about,
or you'd like to hear
from other developers?
FRED CHUNG: If you think about
designing for a platform,
designing for an API,
it is a hard task.
It's difficult.
And it's hard to get it
right on your first try.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we want
to get it right for developers.
FRED CHUNG: And admittedly,
we don't get it right
all the time.
And that's why we want
to listen to developers.
We actually see advocacy
as a two-way street.
Not only do we want
to educate developers
on certain best
practices, but we also
want to use the opportunities
to learn from developers--
their pain points, their
difficulties, their challenges,
their improvement
suggestions on the product.
And then a big
part of what we do
is to work with internal teams,
product, and engineering teams,
to provide the feedback that we
hear from developers so that we
can improve the products.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I've
learned so much, Fred.
Thanks.
And it's been great to
hear about how Google
is a two-way street in advocacy
and how we're listening
to feedback from developers.
And developers, please
take advantage of that.
All the avenues that
Fred has mentioned
are in the description below.
They'll also be right at
the end of this video.
We'd love to hear from you.
We want to build
better APIs, and we
want to build a better
platform that will
allow you to build better apps.
Thanks for watching this far
in this episode of "Coffee
with a Googler."
And thanks most of all
for Fred for being here
and being our
special guest today.
FRED CHUNG: Thanks for
having me, Laurence.
[MUSIC PLAYING]